how's going bros my name is para para
with me today we're gonna play three
games and forever Lewis's we're gonna do
a best out of three okay and this is
obviously what I've learned us with the
girlfriend whoever whoever loses it has
to be tweeted I the winner gets to tweet
with their account then what okay you
are surprisingly fine with this
you never even played this game
the first game is battle golf mmm let's
begin the goal of this game is to a golf
against each other yeah no I got my golf
skills really helps in this one yeah I
got one oh yeah well it's like pursuit
of three years I'm havin em no no no
what excuse me now don't shoot me no
dammit
what oh my god oh you're never gonna hit
the octopus only I can get the octopus
yes what do you do when you can't shoot
me the octopus is impossible
I'm clicking my knees lord I can't no
maybe you need to be tight
maybe you tried to weigh that I have a
bowl right there all right obviously the
game is filthy and that's why I was
losing mm-hmm yeah let's give that
another try but I have to
you are one up with me how about that
yeah okay can you stop gobo gobo gobo oh
yeah you're so bad so yeah all right
it's okay you only have to get four more
[Music]
okay it's okay
you still have a chance to win what they
can still see you okay this is wrestling
well I'm gay work ladies I'm just one
time you it was very precious to me and
you go over the city you didn't remember
okay two player versus this game is
about wrestling you are the one with the
hats I am
oh god this is complicated I smell those
two buns Oh Oh lovely yeah you have to
use both hands
oh where are you going are you going
give me a hug give me no no no no no you
can't you're gonna break to the iPad huh
no no man let me go yeah video game Oh
what are you doing
let go of my face No that's it no no no
I got you now suicide don't stand on my
entity smells yeah
I am are you doing ya know what I think
I won no I definitely won wheresoever
ever wins this one wins yes okay what
are you doing is this whoa
why did she do that
okay fine that's just just to make it
more interesting all right
don't don't get ahead of yourself mm-hmm
so where every wins this one wins so do
you remember a long time ago we played
tug the table or something like that I
think you'll recognize this cuz a lot of
people made copies of that game that we
played cuz we're the og players all
right this game is actually fun um so
it's another wrestling game so you can
only flex your legs oh yeah you like
that oh no you don't remember playing
game like this what are you doing
buddies no no red cap damn it alright
since first define what how is that even
a point no no no no yeah oh I'm just
gonna stand here how are you doing I
love ever holding hands have our hands
like merged together whoa what are you
doing this stop this nonsense that's
what you get
yes alright whoever wins this one is
that this is it yeah don't be too sad
now let's go back
oh there we go oh you tweeter ruining it
crashed it couldn't handle it
wait did I tweet it aren't you okay
you're supposed to be upset yeah I
better hurt maybe not for long because I
have to go in your haircut now all right
is this guy recalled resume thanks so
much for watching and that's not always
stay on don't flirt with my brush
[Music]